you're involved in so many different
things how do you edit the time that you
spend on any one thing in a given day
most of all the way I actually scale It
Is by not beating up myself when I
realized it wasn't good what makes me
work Mark and what makes people like me
work and what I would love to get some
of the listeners to start to consider is
what actually allows me to play it the
way I'm playing it is the lack of
judgment when I didn't play it well too
many people beat themselves up instead
of using it as a learning experience I'm
just refining along the way it's my
relationship with myself where I give
self breathing room to be a human that
allows me to keep doing things and
making them better because I'm tasting
different things because I am taking
quote unquote time risk on a daily basis
which makes the learning from the
outcome of it pro or con a learning that
I can build up you grew up in New Jersey
um your your family had a wine business
that's really ultimately propelled you
into many of the things that you've done
just give us a quick view of that I was
born in the US Sr I came here when I was
three and a half my dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store in Clark New
Jersey he lived his American Dream by
saving all his money from his two three
four five doll an hour salary it was
really like that in 1980 81 82
eventually bought a small liquor store
in Springfield New Jersey in 83 very
small I'm talking 800 square foot little
house first floor on Milbourne Avenue in
1980 he built up a business worked his
face off worked every hour I wear saw
him in my childhood and uh in 1989 he
built a larger store um on that same
property Shoppers Discount Liquors and
he built his American dream and we went
from dead poor living in a studio
apartment with multiple family members
and queens to living a middle class life
in Edison New Jersey um and uh and at 14
I got dragged into that business when I
was 10 11 12 13 it's interesting when
you said Wine Library which is the brand
I changed it into so my dad really had
liquor a real package store liquor and
beer um I brought a lot of the wine
energy to the business by educating
myself in my high school years on wine
and becoming the wine buyer the deao
wine buyer literally while I was still
in high school um but it was interesting
when you just said propelled you to
everything else which is absolutely true
where my brain went was selling trading
cards sports cards in the JCC's and in
the malls of New Jersey the holiday ends
and the Fire Stations between the ages
of 11 and 14 really propelled me no no
[__] and really even lemonade and
shoveling snow and washing cars like
it's really interesting when I think
about my career it really does start at
seven when I did lemonade at 78910 I
spent more time making signs than I did
on making the lemonade and then in
baseball cards I mean when you're 12 13
years old making a thousand dollars a
weekend in the
80s you're really like and you know this
is in hindsight I was like oh I really
had it and by the time I came to my
dad's business when I was 14 Mark I'll
tell you I had like real subconscious
understanding of consumer Behavior
already like I was literally as a
freshman in high school and my dad lived
we lived I lived 45 minutes from the
store the store was in Springfield I
lived in hun County New Jersey we'd ride
down 78 from Exit 12 to exit 48 and I
would spend like like when I think now
back to the convers I had with my father
I wish I was recording them it's really
like wild I I don't even know where I
got it from it was such Natural
Instincts I would talk about like Dad
Dad do you realize like when people
first walk in the store we can't have
these $5 wines hit them when they first
walk in we should put $20 wines there
because everyone's grabbing them and
yeah 20 bucks is less not everyone's
going to grab them but here's the margin
and I changed the way our registers and
brought in like it was just like I was
talking real stuff real Shopper
marketing by the language that everybody
here would be listening
to and then obviously you know by be
that was 1990 and by the time 1998
rolled around four years of high school
four years of college in between I
become incredibly knowledgeable about
wine but more importantly for the
argument or the discussion here I
launched the website in 1997 started
building it in '96 e-commerce wine
retail which was unheard of I started an
email newsletter which was really really
early in
1997 that allowed me to outflank the
Sher LeMans and the zakies and the
morels the premium wine stores of New
York City um because they were doing
cataloges and spending a lot of money on
making them and sending them in the mail
and I was getting into people's inboxes
in the late 90s with Opus One and
Dominus and shat a feat before they were
by months at a time back then and then
Google AdWords right I I bought Google
AdWords when they first came out and was
able to outflank everybody with intent
based marketing and then YouTube came
along I started a wine show on YouTube
in 2006 February of 2006 and that really
repelled me and the business to another
Stratosphere and you know Wine Library
became one of the largest independent
wine retailers in America and I I did
that in my early 20s and it became the
foundation of how I thought about things
because I knew that I was going to leave
my father business at some point because
I knew that it wasn't mine and he was
going to give it to me when he dies and
I'm 47 my dad just turned 70 this two
weekends ago and he's healthy as an ox
and you know he's gonna live to 100 and
I didn't want to inherit it at 80 you
know and so especially because he wasn't
paying me anything mark my dad never
paid me that much money and so all my
20s and early 30s I knew I had to do
something for myself at some point which
meant I had to build a brand I knew that
when I left my dad would go go back to
his old behaviors and he has and I knew
that would be at the detriment of the
business so if I built a huge brand I
knew that it would take him more time to
decrease the business but while I was
building that brand every day my dad
cared about how much money was coming
through the register so I was trained in
sales and brand and that as you can
imagine has serviced me incredibly well
when in my mid-30s I entered into the
Fortune 500 marketing Arena and created
a new version of an agency which I think
has done well in caring about short and
long-term business results sales and
brand and not wasting a penny because
that was definitely Sasha bayner Chip's
biggest fear that I would do some sort
of marketing behavior that return
nothing and so I got very fortunate that
I was trained in the trenches of a
family business but had the natural
ability to understand how that
translated to Fortune 500 land and
that's been a big factor in our growth
you mentioned grateful a couple times
and I've seen a post that you had put
out on LinkedIn a while ago about being
grateful taking a deep breath you know
so much that about the things that we
worry about really doesn't matter can
you elaborate a little bit on
that you know it's funny reading my bio
which I was literally thinking like oh I
gotta talk to my team or my PR team like
I need to add like desperate in that bio
and also as an entrepreneur that's
desperate to scale kindness and
eliminate fear
and and I literally just thought that
seven minutes ago when we were doing the
intro I could see your mind I could see
your mind going as I was reading it that
you were like you know that's not what
he wants yeah first of all great
intuition it was like I'm fine with it
and for the people that don't know me
it's important to like create context I
get it I'm agnostic to it I don't need
it but I definitely am passionate and
I'm pumped that you just went there um I
really dislike fear like genuinely I
think it's weaponized I think I think
parents misuse it I think the government
really misuses it and I think it leads
to a lot of anxiety and a lot of the
things that all of us fear in society
right now I think we all fear suicide I
think we all fear you know shootings at
schools I think we all fear you know the
separation we're getting from our
neighbors on politics and religion and
social issues I even fear very
aggressively the the generational
Warfare that the world is pushing gen Z
versus Boomers I I I don't like fear and
so as I built my company out from zero
people or two me and my brother which
was really what it was to the 2,000
employees we have globally now across
the world um I spend most of my time
trying to eliminate fear inside my four
walls as I've worked with Fortune 500
companies I've realized fear is a real
real thing reporting bonus structures HR
like these are all like real
Fascinations to me and so you know I
just want the world to be happier and I
do think gratitude and accountability
are two incredible places for the
majority people listen to this podcast
that will speed up the process of
eliminating their anxiety and making
them happier hour by hour day by day
accountability is a big one because I
think we point fingers too much it's my
boss's fault it's the Republican's fault
it's the democrat's fault it's my
parents' fault with how theyve you know
raised me and all of them can be
grounded in micr truths but the most
macro truth is you're in control you can
go to therapy you can quit like you can
take a financial step back to leave a
bad job you can do a lot of things as a
human being especially by the way this
is important contextually Mark anyone
who's listening to this podcast from
your or my
circles it like if you have the time to
listen to this podcast it means you have
the capacity for change do you know what
I mean like like nobody in a third world
country that doesn't have electricity is
listening to this podcast you know what
I mean or access to clean water which
750 million people on Earth I'm on the
board of Charity water 750 million
people Mark do not have access to clean
water on Earth
wow and we're complaining about like our
Wi-Fi slow in our apartment or like or
like somebody said a joke and you didn't
like it like like we're really in a
place where perspective is being lost
we're looking for we're looking for
headaches we're looking to get into
conflict right now we're just in this
weird spot and I get it I'm deeply
empathetic I'm so empathetic that it
drives content like gratitude like how
about instead of what sucks right now
how about what you thinking about what's
good like I had four to five things
already it's a 1:46 PM Easter right now
I've had four to five things that a
executive of a business could dwell on
happened today already today and I just
think people complain about dumb [__]
and they don't lean into gratitude and
gratitude starts with the well-being of
the people you love the most starting
with yourself
and so yeah talk about gratitude a lot
you talk about also time and you know
there's you know we all have limited
amount of time how do you edit yourself
you're involved in so many different
things you know I've read one of the
things that you know you kind of do is
you know you believe in 15minute
meetings but how do you edit the time
that you spend on any one thing in a
given day surrounding myself with great
people because I can afford it now and
intuition so I have three full-time
admins I have two chief of staffs that's
a lot of human infrastructure for some
who has a holding company with eight
companies and then many other companies
outside of it investing vehicles and all
the personal life and real life and
being a public figure just speaking and
doing a like this this you know you know
like I really wanted to do this and I
know you've been incredibly patient and
we've had some stop and starts and I'm
not cancelling in August because I want
to it's because I am getting pulled in a
million different directions and there
are a lot of fires and like the logic of
my infrastructure team is like this fire
is probably more important this podcast
yes that's right but on the flip side
I'm a human being and I like you
obviously I really like your daughter
she spent some time here and I want to
do this and so you know you're going on
a little bit of humanity mixed in with
with operational excellence right you're
like trying to be efficient you're using
smart people around you but you're also
going on intuition you know I do so many
meetings that don't look right on paper
that five years later you're like if I
didn't take that meeting it wouldn't
have led to this and so I'm trying to do
a little bit of mix of the gray and the
black and white but most of all this is
going to be powerful for people most of
all the way I actually scale It Is by
not beating up myself when I realized it
wasn't good what makes me work Mark and
what makes people like me work and what
I would love to get some of the
listeners to start to consider is what
actually allows me to play it the way
I'm playing it is the lack of judgment
when I didn't play it
well too many people beat themselves up
instead of using it as a learning
experience I'm just refining along the
way and it's my it's my relationship
with myself where I give myself
breathing room to be a human that allows
me to keep doing things and making them
better because I'm tasting different
things because I am taking quote unquote
time risk on a daily basis which makes
the learning from the outcome of it pro
or con a learning that I can build on in
your businesses you know part of what
you've done a great job and you've
talked about it a bunch already is the
content that you produce you know I've
been in the retail space for a long long
time and often times it's difficult to
get retailers to produce the right
content and I'm putting air quotes
around right how do you and and your
organizations you know get with your
clients to demonstrate to them you know
that they need a full view of content
it's not only one channel you talked
about the Wine Library and the things
that you were doing with YouTube and
Google AdWords so you know how do you
get the retailer to understand that they
need to produce quality
content my biggest preference is to be
their partner in media and creative and
prove it to them through
sales you know one of like this is one
thing that I always tell young I I meet
a lot of young agency owners these days
um and a lot of them do organic social
and they keep asking me like Gary how do
I keep clients better or how do I get
more clients or how do I prove it this
is obviously the other side of the
spectrum of the Fortune 500 landscape
and I always ask them I'm like well does
service build or business and it's
fascinating how big of an issue that
question is to most of the kids I talk
to because most of them will answer
honestly with I don't know and then I
say well if you're trying to convince
somebody to pay you to grow their
business and you don't know imagine how
bad that is and a lot of times I
encourage them to learn about media
because to answer your question for the
Fortune 500 brands that I work with I
tell all of them hey if we're going to
do content brand creative your
commercials VOR media has done more
Super Bowl commercials in the last five
years than any creative agency in the
world which is a brain twist a lot of
people because they have us me pegged in
social media meanwhile I still think
social media from a day-to-day
standpoint builds more brand than any
campaign work that one can actually do
but I tell every retail client
especially retail more than cpg and
others hey if you really want to hold us
accountable to measure what we're doing
for you give us the media and the
creative and we'll show it to you in
sales because if I have the media and
the creative I can and should be held
accountable to sales if we just have the
creative I tell them I'm at the mercy of
how you measure brand what report what
internal mmms or like how do you do it
because all of you are doing it in a
fluffy way you've all accepted some sort
of mm MMA you know Neilon brandli study
brand score all of it is fake math and I
have to be at the mercy of how you do
that and I have to reverse engineer into
that but my biggest preference is doing
it the way Mark they had they had this
industry right for a long time media and
creative together Under One Roof one as
they the to choke one throat to choke
and like we as an agency um want that
accountability I I'd rather get fired
for us falling short with full control
than being fired for a subjective
opinion that they didn't like the video
we made or if it's not on brand or or
the way we spent their media is like on
on lowcost Impressions is a that's a
fake API so you know I think we're very
good at talking business comma Marketing
in a world where I think people are
doing marketing for the sake of
marketing you often give predictions
about the future of the internet and
Retail and digital in general you know
we're recording in in September 2023
we're obviously getting close to Holiday
uh what does your crystal ball say about
you know retail the spend this holiday
and as we move into
2024 I think I think consumer confidence
is a little shaky and we're gonna have
like think about what we're walking into
there I don't have to use a crystal ball
like retail struggling right now in
September like there's really no
rationale to why it should spin up and
get aggressive other than American
consumers and Global consumers love to
Deb and so you know there's there's no
rationale for it to be a good season but
it might be a great season because if
people are feeling down and worried
sometimes it's like binge eating right I
do it I do I I sometimes get mad that
I'm not eating as well as I'm supposed
to be and you know what I do I double
down on bad eating because I'm on tilt
it's like gambling right you're like you
double down so there is a path towards
it being solid which is ah [__]
everything's [__] up let mey buy
another TV or another outfit or and I
get that that's how consumers work my
intuition is that's not how it's going
to play out I think you're already
seeing people you know cut one of their
streaming services cut down on their
Uber like you're seeing it everywhere so
I expect it to be a pretty conservative
holiday
season um so I think it'll be solid to
solid soft um I think there'll be plenty
of retailers that do well because
they'll outflank their competition on
price or something of that nature I
think some will do poorly even though
they outflank they're going to take on
too many cogs meaning they're going to
over rely on free shipping or Price
which is going to make them highly
unprofitable um and then I think there's
another thing we should talk about and
with full eyes wide open we're about to
kick off presidential election season
here in America for assuming most people
are listening are in America and we're
gonna be in full swing by the holidays
you know it's coming we got a bunch more
Republican debates the election this
year you know and off you know November
election will happen which means we are
now fully countdown to the presidential
election come Black Friday come
Christmas season and you know I think
it's going to be highly contentious
we're on tilt emotions are high and when
there's that level of anxiety confidence
is not where it needs to be and so I
think my crystal ball is not a crystal
ball I think it's very practical to
think that at best case scenario it'll
be a solid season there is no
exceptional in the forecast yeah it
certainly feels that way a lot of the
folks that listen to this show Gary are
kind of early in their career and you do
an event called
vcon um what is vcon and and actually
more specifically you had a great call
out um that I I saw about resumés and
how they should be used today um you
know for folks can you talk about that
really quick on vcon Von is a super
conference I think of it as like the
coolest business conference
we uh throw it each year the third
Year's coming up we're about to announce
where that is very shortly here it will
be on next summer um the last two were
in Indianapolis and Min one in Minnesota
one in Indianapolis both at the football
stadiums 10,000 people all of which
bought the original vriend nft
collectible which was a receipt for the
three-year ticket to this conference
because I was kind of anticipating the
nft you know speculation so I wanted to
make sure that people got something of
value if they bought my collectible V
friends is like a Pokemon meet Sesame
Street intellectual property that I'm
building think Hannah Barbara think
Marvel I'm on that Journey um and and uh
and so it's a really really exciting
conference like high star powered Neil
Patrick Harris Drew Barrymore Jessica
Alba Snoop Dogg those kind of characters
but tons of CMOS of Fortune 500
companies a lot of like Innovative Tech
leaders and so really excited about the
next one as far as resumés you know like
boy I think people's content is a better
res like you know I don't know about you
and you've been through it like I don't
know if I've ever called to reference on
a resume in my career because when I'm
getting those resumés like they're
loaded right like of course you're G to
put the three references that you've
triple checked that if I call them
they're gonna say you were epic that's
like logical I don't see that as a bad
thing I just don't think of it as good
data right and and more importantly what
we were doing at scale at vayer X and
definitely many of the companies I
invest and I'm encouraging them as well
is like people are putting out content
now like the resume is being done on
LinkedIn with the content by the way I
look at people when they're on the final
stage if it's on my radar on the things
they like I'll give you a good one what
happened recently Mark we were about to
hire a creative director at Vayner media
and everything was perfect and I went
and looked and I looked at all the
things that the person liked and all of
them were way more grounded in the 1991
book how Brands grow and it was very
about subjective Awards and like every
like was about what I believe is a day
that doesn't exist anymore in Madison
Avenue and it was the reason we did not
hire that person wow and and I and I
don't say that out loud for everyone to
listen that that's whether I'm right or
wrong that's a subjective call on
someone's business strategy I believe
that you know being overly addicted to
an ad week headline or a can lion award
or you know believing in subjective
opinions in boardrooms is at the
detriment of contemporary marketing so
that's a concern of mine but that's not
why I'm bringing it up I'm bringing it
up for everybody of like you can get
better insights to people that you're
considering on the public internet on
LinkedIn on Twitter X on their Instagram
and and so I think the modern resume is
clearly one's behavior on the internet
but by the way it's really funny it's
not the cliche thing that us parents
tell our kids like don't put a bikini
picture and don't put like we've hired
unlimited people with beer pong pictures
like that's human that's you being a
human to me at least in our organization
I'm more interested in your
philosophical views on marketing and
that it scares me more that you're G to
like every award show in advertising
more than I'm gonna see a picture of you
when you were in college playing beer
pong of course like who wasn't and so
those are things we think about great
okay we're uh out of time here uh great
passion and um as I said at the
beginning I really appreciate you doing
this and you know my daughter had a
great experience in her internship at at
vayer media that's a while uh now and um
but thank you for uh I'm Gonna Leave You
with something Mark for everybody
there's a new book there's a new book
I'm writing which I hav here's some
Alpha for you here's a scoop I have a
new book coming out I was gonna
originally call it jab jab jab left hook
which was a followup to one of my
successful books jab jab jab right hook
but now I'm calling it day trading
attention we didn't get to this but we
touched on it the concept of what day
trading attention is for all the
marketers listening is understanding how
to Media plan where you don't waste the
penny on potential reach versus
actualized
reach we we have a you want to talk
about a real pandemic we are buying
media Impressions that are not being
actually consumed and then we're putting
videos and pictures in there that nobody
gives a [__]
about so there's a new dawn of like how
building brand and sales this here and I
think it's grounded in trading attention
whether it's an influencer you're
working with whether it's a live event
whether it's buying media on the new
ctvs or the OTS or the fast channels or
on social for the people that grew up in
the game like you and I did we really
got to take a step back and realize 2024
is a new dawn a new era and we've got to
sharpen our marketing tool belts this is
why there's so much pain and confusion
in the system and so um that's not a
plug for the book because it's far away
away we'll be out for a while it's a
plug for everyone understand
understanding it's time to stop wasting
money on potential media Impressions and
on Creative that's too expensive that
isn't making the thing that you want to
happen happen great stuff Gary thanks
very much uh see you
[Music]
soon